الان سنتابع الشان الصينيه والتصعيد مع
الولايات المتحده ردا على التحركاتها
العسكريه الامريكيه وتمدد واشنطن خاصه في
اسيا بدات بكين مجموعه تحركات عسكريه
بحريه حيث مسيرت دوريات حول جزري هينان
وباراسيل في بحر الصين الجنوبيه الدوريات
البحريه الصينيه وافقه بكين تهدف لتفتيش
السفن والمهمه ستستمر لمده شهر كامل
بتوازي ابحرت اكبر سفينه تدريب صينيه الى
اخر محطات جولتها الاقليميه المتمثله
بالفلبين الرحله التي وصفت بالموديات
تستغرق اربعين يوما وتوقفت في فيتنام
وتايلاند وبروناي قبل توجهها للفلبين مرور
السفينه في المنطقه ياتي في وقت يتزايد
قلق واشنطن وحلفائها من انشطه بحريه صينيه
في بحر الصين الجنوبيه
التحرك الصيني ياتي عقب اختتام اول
تدريبات ثلاثيه لخفر سواحل الفلبين
واليابان والولايات المتحده التوترات في
المنطقه ايضا زادها حده حده وضع الفلبين
الشهر الماضي عوامات ملاحيه في جزر
سبرايتلي المتنازع عليها في بحر الصين
الجنوبي ومسارعه الصين للقيام بالمثل
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات